rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée hors des sentiers battus à
cilaos chargées d'histoire la montée
vers le plateau du tap cale sur les
traces du marronnage
rendez vous au fond du cirque de cilaos
à ilet à cordes après cette ligne droite
tourner à droite et vous pourrez vous
garer au bout d'une petite descente
dans cette partie moins connus de cilaos
jérôme turpin 2ème réunion nous propose
une randonnée en direction du plateau du
tap call un site réputé pour avoir
abrité des esclaves marrons
et la première partie commence sur un
sentier balisé pour descendre jusqu'au
bras de saint paul
dans ces écarts d'ilet à cordes
inaccessible par la route
il reste encore quelques cases habiter
ce sont les il a du bras de saint paul
et de grands count on allie les deux
bras de saint-paul beaucoup plus on aura
lie les grands coups de coups nous on va
traverser tout à l'heure si on repart un
peu à ma droite on a tout le plateau
d'ilet à cordes et puis hein il est
abandonné 1 qu'on appelait enfin qu'on
appelle toujours
lille est songe pour prendre la décision
de rester ici
selo faut savoir qu'on a le captage du
bras
dubray lavialle ajustant au donc l'eau
est à proximité
donc quand il ya l'eau il ya la vie donc
les gens restent sur ce plateau son
problème là on est celle est de battre
saint paul il est son j'ai beaucoup plus
haut pour pouvoir tirer de l'eau et
ramener vers le haut à l'époque il y
avait pas tous les moyens qu'on a
actuellement c'est beaucoup plus simple
de se passer en aval d'un
d'une source comme des 100e
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
récupérer cette eau alors qu en altitude
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de la
faire remonter
e
m
à la sortie de l'île est le säntis
s'engage dans la ravine d'ubs raccrocher
un chemin que l'on devine peut emprunter
qui longe la conduite d'eau du captage
du bras de la vierge face à nous la
falaise qu'il faudra gravir pour
atteindre le plateau du tap call
et
et comme un rite de passage une épreuve
nous attendent d'abord la traversée
vertigineuse du bras crochet sur une
passerelle aménagée au dessus de la
conduite d'eau ma fille
quelques câbles une ligne de vie est une
plateforme de seulement 50 cm de large
mieux vaut ne pas avoir le vertige le
long de la conduite d'eau la montée est
raide et puis soudainement il faut
bifurquer sur la droite s'engager en
pleine forêt sur une trace à peine
visible
en or sentiers la progression devient
une aventure inconcevable sans un guide
capable de retrouver suivre la trace
si vous doutez
j'ai vécu
sous les brandes au milieu des ronces
ces raids ça glisse chaque pas est
difficile mais l'on monte vite
lorsque l'on retrouve les eucalyptus est
le signe que nous avons enfin atteint le
bord du plateau et notre but
si au milieu de nulle part d'être à sa
thèse d' ancien campement marron les
murs et les bananiers et surtout la
fameuse pierre gravée découverte par
hasard il ya une quinzaine d'années de
serre qui sont dessinées ainsi que
plusieurs encoches et si plusieurs
hypothèses circulent à son sujet l'une
dont nous sommes sûrs c'est que l'une de
ces encoches indique parfaitement le
nord de quoi bien prendre nos repères
avant de revenir sur nos pas
l'intérêt de cette rando ce que j'aime
c'est que arrivé sur ce plateau on
remonte un peu le temps on remonte un
peu le passé pour venir connaître un peu
l'histoire de l'esclavagé c'est un site
de marronnasse ainsi tout ça a été
prouvé que les esclaves ont trouvé
refuge ici
tapez call notamment qui veut dire en
malgache un tape qu'à la forêt coupée en
deux dès qu'on a vu sur ce plateau on
arrive directement sur le secteur où il
ya la fameuse roches gravées d'où elle
vient comment il était arrivé là qu'il a
fait on ne sait pas trop après il ya
certaines études qui ont montré que ça
pouvait représenter pas mal de choses
notamment un calendrier à malgache des
lieux de
enfin un plan des anciens villages que
comportait le tap call bon le sujet
quand même assez vaste quoi dès qu'on
commence à parler un peu de marronnage à
la réunion des endroits où le marronnage
exister faut savoir que c'est pas des
sentiers balisés
donc c'est des sentiers extrêmement
difficile s'est pas ouvert tout le monde
faut déjà avoir une bonne condition
physique il faut absolument avoir un
guide et à vraiment à pouvoir monter
dans des dénivelés
quand même assez assez raide voire même
très très très très raide ce que j'aime
moins c'est un peu la végétation qu'on
est dedans permanence un dès qu'on
quitte la passerelle pour arriver sur le
plateau takkal on est dans la végétation
avec la la roue cela qui nous agrippe à
chaque fois des confins pas on est
agrippée au pont fait deux pas en
arrière
ensuite c'est comme un tapis roulant
c'est comme s'ils tapent calme nous nous
disaient oui faut mériter en même temps
rester là venez restée aux simples
mystico assez sympa